tomorrow is Thanksgiving but today is
Groundhog's Day because we have entered
the 15th day of election day
15 days and we still don't have all the
results from the midterm elections at
least not in Arizona and it doesn't like
look like we're going to get them
anytime soon because Kerry lake is
refusing to concede the Arizona
gubernatorial election at least two
Counties in Arizona are refusing to
certify the results
and they're all damn right to do it
Carrie lake has referred to evidence
including first-hand witness accounts
the kind of accounts from poll Watchers
that we have played on this show
that there were not only Shenanigans and
irregularities but statutory violations
in the conduct of the election
an election that was overseen by the way
by Katie Hobbs the Arizona Secretary of
State who claims to have won the
governorship
some squishier Republicans are calling
on Kerry Lake to concede but I think she
should take this as far as it can go
because this is not just sour grapes
this is not just some frivolous claim
because the Republicans don't want to
admit they lost
this is the second election in a row in
which Arizona has had all sorts of
problems with voting and Counting and
all the rest of it that just
coincidentally all benefit the Democrats
and we cannot just let this go
Arizona
will very likely decide the 2024
presidential election we went through
the election map the other day on this
show even if all the right things break
for the Republicans Arizona is going to
be key we need to fight this fight over
election Integrity now or we're very
likely not going to be able to put up
much of a fight on the much bigger race
in two years I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Chad who says
correction Michael Biden's biggest
opponents are the chairs not the chairs
the stairs and his Sports code the chair
is too I'm not sure that he even can sit
down and get up all that well you make a
good point Biden's biggest opponent it's
not Trump it's not DeSantis it's not
Buddha judge it's not Kamala it's not
Newsome it is himself he he is
the problem the fault dear Joe dear
Biden lies not in our stars but in
ourselves and in himself especially he's
got to protect himself when you want to
protect your home you got to check out
ring it's Thanksgiving time baby right
now today the day before Thanksgiving
it's biggest travel day of the year I
know a lot of people are going to be
traveling to see our loved ones very
very soon so you might find yourself
away from home it's not just
Thanksgiving it's Christmas it's New
Year's that's why you got to team up
with ring okay with ring security
products you can rest easy knowing that
your home and family are safe when you
are not there the ring doorbell notifies
you and guests or packages arrive Rings
indoor cameras let you keep an eye on
kids and pets while you're away ring
alarm will alert you of any motion
detection while the house is empty plus
if you add smart lighting around your
home you can turn lights on or off while
you are away Rings home security
products don't just help keep your home
and family safe they make perfect gifts
for everybody on your list head on over
to ring.com collection offers to find
out how you can live less stressed this
season with a ring product that is right
for you that's ring.com collections
slash offers
the Arizona election issues which are
not fantasies which are not just a
coping mechanism but which are very real
and which have gone on for two elections
in a row now and have benefited
Democrats and in Arizona where a lot of
these issues are going on even the
Republicans who are playing a role in
conducting the elections are declared
never Trump Republicans who hate the
mega candidates who raise money to fight
the Maga candidates and
once is a coincidence once is a fluke
twice some people might want to call it
a coincidence I think what we're seeing
here is a strategy okay and that's not
the only impediment for Trump in 2024.
another major impediment for Trump is
that the Supreme Court has just decided
to allow the Democrats to look at his
taxes
Trump's taxes have been an issue for six
years now
the Democrats have been trying to get a
hold of them Donald Trump just like any
presidential candidate has no obligation
to release his tax returns and because
Trump is the first businessman to run
for president in a very long time uh
first guy who had not held political
office before he became a presidential
candidate so his whole career was in
business he had a gigantic business
Empire he made Mitt Romney look like a
pauper okay when you look at Romney's
business Holdings compared to Trump's
and so obviously his taxes were going to
be very complicated Trump was under
audit already so he said I'm not going
to release my taxes there's no reason
for me to
if if I release my taxes I a businessman
with obviously a complicated tax history
and use some random career politician
who does not have very complicated taxes
then you're going to find a lot more
dirt in my stuff then I'm going to be
able to find in yours just that's just
the nature of business so he says I'm
not going to do it and the Supreme Court
has just decided no
they denied the Trump legal team's
request that the taxes be withheld
the Congressional committee will now
take a look at this they're going to
have a pretty limited window to do this
though because once the Republicans take
over the house officially in January
they are going to shut that down
so we'll see if the Democrats can get
their act together to dig through
Trump's taxes in time to get anything
worthwhile but it's just a reminder
the Democrats are still trying to take
Trump down and it's one of the strongest
Arguments for Trump's candidacy in 2024
is they clearly view him as the big
threat that's why they're exhausting
every legal mechanism every political
mechanism every media mechanism to stop
this guy from running okay so if it
really were the case that Trump is so
easy to beat he's the one Republican who
can lose to Joe Biden if that were
really the case then the Democrats would
not be spending this much time and
effort and money to to stop his
candidacy before it even really begins
now that's not the only challenge for
Trump there's another big Challenge from
Trump this one coming from the
Republican side and that is that Ron
DeSantis is doing great right now okay
if the midterms taught us anything it's
don't necessarily trust the polls but
take it with a grain of salt I guess
when you're looking at these poles they
are breaking for Ron DeSantis
okay this is big news the neighborhood
research and media poll
which was released yesterday showed that
32 percent of respondents in Iowa so
this is the first state that holds its
caucuses to determine the course of the
primary
the very
first state is saying that they are
breaking for Ron DeSantis 32 percent
want DeSantis 30 percent want Trump this
poll reflects a 23-point swing toward
DeSantis from June so you might say 32
to 30 who cares they're in a dead heat
sure but DeSantis was way down he was
barely a blimp back in June and so you
see now after the summer or after the
fall after the midterms that kind of
momentum for DeSantis means that
DeSantis potentially could consolidate
the party behind him
the conventional wisdom had been if
Trump declares that he's running he
clears the field that's even what some
prospective candidates were banking on
that hasn't necessarily happened
DeSantis hasn't declared that he's
running yet but he's behaving as though
he's going to run now this the second
conventional wisdom barring the first is
that Trump runs but he's weakened so
then Ron DeSantis gets in and then
everybody gets it the idea being if
someone is actually willing to challenge
Trump's hegemony in the Republican party
then everyone's going to do it and
you're going to get DeSantis and Haley
and Tim Scott and Cruz and Hawley and
Rand Paul and just everybody else
everyone's going to jump in
but the thing about conventional wisdom
is it's almost always wrong the
consensus view almost always wrong and
so then
you've got this third option that is
that is
appearing to be more and more plausible
which is that Trump declares early
the party does not consolidate behind
him Ron DeSantis does say that he's
going to run
and Ron DeSantis consolidates the party
behind him
you've seen DeSantis taking the lead in
polls in New Hampshire taking the lead
noun polls in Iowa if he starts to take
the lead in polls like South Carolina
and Florida and other early States
all of a sudden
Trump's path to the nomination is
looking much more in doubt
I don't put a lot of stock in these
prognostications two years earlier I
I've repeatedly said on this show in
2014 no one would have guessed Trump in
2010 no one would have guessed Romney
the people that were being talked about
then were people that we now forget
their names Haley Barber Mitch Daniels
Bobby Jindal okay so I'm just saying
Ron DeSantis is playing his cards
absolutely perfectly there is a path now
there is a every day it seems like a
clearer path for Ron DeSantis to beat
Donald Trump for the nomination even in
a head-to-head battle that is something
that that very very few people if
anybody would have predicted even two or
three months ago now is that going to
happen I'm not convinced of that why
because Trump has a secret weapon and
the secret weapon is the Democrats the
best hope for Donald Trump right now is
for the Democrats to keep going after
him because as I mentioned just five
minutes ago the more that the media and
the Democrats Focus their ire and their
fire on Trump and not on DeSantis that
is a sign and I think it's a pretty
legit sign to Republican voters that the
liberal establishment considers Trump to
be the real threat if the establishment
puts all its fire on Ron DeSantis that's
going to be a signal that they consider
DeSantis to be the real threat but they
are putting their fire on Trump you've
got a Democrat Congressman Jamie Raskin
saying the Democrats will prosecute
Donald Trump
if he is making this in part
believing that this will somehow protect
him from investigations or indictments
is is that accurate do you think
no it's absolutely wrong
um in fact the people who made that
point most emphatically were his
defenders in the Senate during the
second impeachment trial who said that
the proper way to deal with a former
president who has engaged in criminality
is to prosecute him rather than to
impeach him if he's already left office
now of course that contradicted more
than two centuries of understanding that
a public official does not have to still
be in office in order to be impeached
tried and convicted but in any event
everybody agreed that he could be tried
this contradicted centuries of America
give me a break no one has ever
impeached a president after he's left
office the whole thing is insane the
whole Democrat treatment of Donald Trump
was completely unprecedented but they're
sending this signal we're going after
him we're going to prosecute him we're
going to keep him off the ballot we're
going to do everything we can okay I
think Donald Trump should be encouraging
that I think that what the Democrats are
doing to Donald Trump right now should
be considered an in-kind contribution to
the Trump campaign if the man is
anti-fragile to use a phrase from the
author a Nassim Nicholas Talib okay the
man some people
they can they can withstand stuff you
know they're they're resilient they're
durable some people the minute they face
any adversity they crack those people
are fragile and they're then there are
some rare people who get stronger the
more you attack them and this would be a
concept described by Talib as
anti-fragile that is Trump and that is
especially Trump in 2024. the more the
Democrats throw at him the stronger he
will seem and the stronger he will be
and that that's what we've got to figure
out okay when we're trying to hire
somebody to be our President we want the
best guy for the job and so we got to
consider a lot of different options when
you want the best guy for the job at
your company you got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now head on over to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles I'm grateful
for so many people in my life I'm
grateful for sweet little Elisa grateful
for the rest of my family I'm very
grateful for you I'm also grateful for
my colleagues okay we can be grateful
for those who make our work lives easier
that is why it is so important to have
the right people on your team and if you
want to hire those people for your
business you need ZipRecruiter you can
try it for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com Knowles ZipRecruiter
uses powerful matching technology to
find and match the right candidates up
with your job you can easily review
these recommended candidates invite them
to apply right out of those top choices
additionally zip recruiters complete
Suite of tools makes it so easy to
filter review and rate your candidates
four out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day so if you want a
stress-free hiring process trust me you
will be very thankful that you tried
ZipRecruiter go to our special URL try
it right now for free ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com ZipRecruiter the
smartest way to hire
tomorrow is Thanksgiving
I assume people are looking forward to
seeing family
and having pumpkin pie
maybe watching a little football
cracking open a couple coca-colas you
know having a nice relaxing time all
together with your family especially
after these past two years where the
political establishment has forced us
not to see our families not to get
together has upended so many of our
Traditions so much of our way of life
well not so fast you
not so fast you because Dr found she has
something else in mind
the real world ba45 that has been
circulating and we know that that is
really quite good so we have
immunological data and you have now
clinical efficacy data everybody was
asking the question where's the clinical
efficacy data now it has come out with
the CDC mmwr this morning so we know
it's safe we know that it is effective
so my message and my final message may
be the final message I give you from
this Podium is that please for your own
safety for that of your family get your
updated covid-19 shot as soon as you're
eligible to protect yourself your family
and your community I urge you to visit
vaccines.gov to find a location where
you can easily get an updated vaccine
and please do it as soon as possible
thank you
you gotta give the guy credit he just
doesn't give it up he does not give it
up don't now listen here you
before you go out to your Thanksgiving
make sure you take the 17th highly
effective shot
so effective that you only need 75 more
of them before it starts to seem a
little bit effective maybe probably not
get your shot take the jab sheep
what we are seeing from Dr fauci here
and and the reporters we're having a
field day over this I mean even the
conservatives obviously were the ones
pushing back the most but people have
had it with Dr fauci okay because Dr
fauci has lied to us he actually lied to
us don't forget he's gotten a lot of
things wrong going back to the 1980s and
especially during covet he got a ton of
stuff wrong about the safety of the
vaccines about the efficacy of the
vaccines right which even now the NIH
will admit was not totally right not
totally effective okay uh but he's also
lied he lied about his views of the
masks
he went on TV and he said Don't wear
masks mask is a dump
don't wear them and then five seconds
later he said okay wear all the masks
you have to wear the masks and when when
the reason I say was a lie because lies
are intentional is
when he was asked to explain this
contradiction he said well at the time I
thought they might be a shortage of
masks and I wanted to save them for the
public health people
oh so you you lied you said something
that you that you believed was not true
to get a political end that you wanted
that's called lying and so people have
had it with this guy obviously but what
Dr fauci is demonstrating right now is a
principle
that those of us who are from New York
or who have spent any time in New York
are familiar with especially if you are
from the Italian-American community and
it is a principle called deny till you
die
and that's what she's doing this guy
he could get caught little little baby
fauci could get caught with his hand in
the cookie jar and Mama fauci could come
come into the kitchen and say Eddie what
are you doing I don't know why she
sounds like sweet little Elisa Anthony
there you
and he was like I'm not eating any
cookies she's like I see your hair I
think about that it's very high pitched
I can't take anymore
the mother would say I see your hand in
the cookie jar
and little baby fauci would say no you
don't no it's not in the cookie jar and
he would go to his grave
maintaining that his hand was not in the
cookie jar he'll just keep up the ACT
okay he is absolutely Shameless he he
does not care whatsoever and so Dr fauci
is going to Pedal the dubious vaccines
he is going to Peddle the Preposterous
arbitrary Health recommendations like
stand six feet away and wear the hanky
over your face
until the end of time or until we take
power away from him
he's going to do it if if you want to
have a normal Thanksgiving and have a
normal life and have a normal country
we've got to stop
the Dr fauces of the world from having
power
speaking of
members of the Biden Administration that
I don't like very much
Pete butterjudge
Pete bootage has come out in the wake of
a shooting in Colorado which seemed to
Target people for being LGBT uh Pete
bootage
has come out and said he doesn't want
conservatives thoughts and prayers
there has always been a relationship
between the social and political
demonization of a group and that group's
vulnerability to being physically
attacked and it is completely
unacceptable and I don't want to hear
thoughts and prayers from somebody who
has been actively singling out this
group for hate fear and whether they say
so or not ultimately for violence
I don't want your thoughts and prayers
you evil conservatives because you're
the reason that this happened you you
conservatives
are the reason
that this this hateful far-right fascist
conservative right-winger
shot up this gay club
right that's what Pete Buddha judge is
telling you
which is very ironic
because
people to judge m Joe Biden
have four years demonized conservatives
so if people to judge's principle is
that if you criticize a group or if you
invade against a group that you are then
responsible for violence against that
group Then Pete Buddha judge and
especially Joe Biden would have a lot of
blood on their hands Joe Biden has spent
the last six months calling parents
terrorists concerned parents or domestic
terrorists and said
that conservatives are far-right Fascist
existential threats to our democracy
okay but furthermore even the premise of
Pete Buddha judge's whining is and his
his really vicious attack on
conservatives is false because the guy
who shot up the club according to
attorneys according to the news reports
right now was not some far-right Maga
hat wearing conservative guy
he was a member of the LBG the LGBT
community
the guy who shot up the club according
to the attorneys according to the news
reports it identifies as non-binary
so as usual you know I didn't report on
this shooting right when it happened not
because I don't care about the shooting
obviously any shooting is very very sad
but because I just knew that the media
reports were going to be BS in the the
first 24 hours like they always are
on this show we we usually don't have
knee-jerk reactions right to to these
sorts of news stories and the reason for
that is because
after these big events that can be
exploited by political activists there
is a ton of propaganda and you don't
really know what's true and what's not
it's kind of like the war in Ukraine no
one has any idea what is actually
happening in Ukraine because there's a
ton of Russian propaganda and there's a
ton of Western propaganda and a lot of
it is BS don't forget just a a week or
so ago we were almost on the brink of
World War III because of news reports
that Russia fired a missile into Poland
and then it turned out it wasn't Russia
that fired the missile it was Ukraine
that fired the missile and so the the
idea that this would trigger Article 5
and we had to go bomb the Kremlin
was Preposterous it was actually the
opposite of reality
well same thing here
I just knew that these news reports were
going to be dubious and they were going
to be filled with a lot of propaganda
and that's what's happening now
furthermore though furthermore to Pete's
point
what degree of Pride does it take to say
I don't want your prayers
it just it just takes a lot of pride
pun unintended but pride is the queen of
all vices okay pride is the deadliest of
the seven deadly sins and to say I don't
want your prayers is to say I'll do it
myself I'm good enough in myself I don't
need you I don't need the help of God I
just we should always be praying we
should always be praying we should
always welcome prayers from anybody we
should welcome prayers from our worst
enemies we should pray for our worst
enemies we should all this is a very
very Fallen World okay and the only hope
you've got is is to pray and Pete Buddha
judge doesn't get it and the Democrats
don't get it at all and their their view
of the world is just so backwards and
that pride in that hubris
uh I think conceals for them the
absurdity and the hypocrisy of their
very statement
conservatives are evil fascists terrible
threats to our very democracy they're
terrorists and also if you ever
criticize anybody you're guilty of
committing violence against them
no conservative criticisms legitimate
and they're legitimate criticisms of the
LGBT activist movement that pushes
Dragon Story Hour in schools and tries
to cut off little kids genitals none of
them none of the criticisms that the
right makes of those people
come anywhere close to what Joe Biden
has said
when Joe Biden says conservatives by
your very existence you pose a threat to
our entire country your terrorists
when it doesn't even come close okay so
I just don't want to hear it from people
to judge but I don't want to hear
anything from people to judge as it so
happens all right I just the people who
are running our country are not doing a
good job things are chaotic that's why
you got to invest in gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 inflation continues
to bedevil our economy the daily wire
reports that in less than two years
inflation has gone from 1.4 percent to
8.6 percent as of May 2022 the price of
gas was up nearly 49 price of meat
poultry and fish all up about 14.2
percent price of used cars was up 16 the
current administration's irresponsible
spending patterns including the 1.9
trillion dollar rescue plan continue to
exacerbate the problem now is not the
time to have all your money tied up in
the stock market do not let your savings
wither away hedge against inflation with
gold from Birch gold text nulls kwles to
98 98 98 and Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on protecting your savings
with gold Birch gold is giving it a free
gold bar with any Purchase made by
December 22nd but you must submit your
claim by Black Friday with almost 20
years of experience in converting IRAs
and 401ks into precious metals IRAs
Birch gold can help you too
Do not sit around while the fed devalues
your hard-earned money text nulls kwles
to 98 98.98 learn how you can convert at
least part of your savings into a
precious metals Ira if you place an
order by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar text nulls
Canon wles to 98 98 98
speaking of the sexual Revolution really
bizarre story just happened here in my
state of Tennessee
a Tennessee couple just made history
by welcoming in their new twins these
twins are biologically not theirs
biologically adopted but they weren't
adopted in the normal way they were
adopted as Frozen embryos as Frozen
embryos that were conceived in 1992.
so these babies were conceived in 1992
put in a freezer for 30 years and then
this couple in Tennessee adopted the
embryos and gave birth to them
they are both these little children are
the couple's youngest kids and oldest
kids these little babies are
about as old as I am actually
even though they're little babies and
the whole thing is really really strange
the main takeaway here I think
people are going to be debating the uh
bioethics of
uh embryo adoption
and I I don't really know exactly what
to think of embryo adoption in a way it
seems quite wrong because you're
separating the procreative act from the
conjugal Act
uh although it's not obviously it was
not the couple that did this but the
couple is involved in the implantation
and so that seems to me bioethically
dubious but on the other hand you've got
these Frozen people that are just Frozen
in perpetuity and then a couple comes in
and says we're gonna we're gonna
actually allow you guys to have life and
not just leave you Frozen in perpetuity
that seems like a wonderful thing and so
everyone's going to be focused on the
bioethics of is embryo adoption okay is
it not okay are there questions about it
whatever to me that's a secondary point
I don't have an answer on that point yet
though I am somewhat cautious about it
the real
takeaway here I think is that IVF is
just absolutely awful it's just
absolutely unacceptable I know a lot of
people have used IVF I know a lot of
people have been tricked into using IVF
and I know a lot of people are grateful
to IVF because there are children who
are walking around today exist because
of IVF and and so I'm I'm not asking you
to you know regret your children or
something like that obviously the kids
are a good end and sometimes people
engage in these things unwittingly and
out of desperation out of ignorance but
good Ends don't justify immoral means
and I think the more we look into IVF
it's so clear this is immoral just look
at those two little kids
those little kids are real kids they're
real people
and they've been real people for 30
years in a in this Frozen stasis in a
freezer okay and there are lots and lots
and lots of people like this and that is
the result it is frankly the inevitable
result of a regime that tolerates in
vitro fertilization
and so if those two little kids are real
people
then all those embryos and all those
freezers are real people too
and for every two little kids they get
born and adopted 30 years later think of
all the people think of all the souls
that are in those freezers that is just
unacceptable and no no desire to resolve
infertility which often they're not in
all cases but but often can be resolved
in other ways that are not so
bioethically compromised
but that is that is not those are real
kids okay if you doubted before that the
the souls on Ice were real people those
are real kids and so it's Gotta It's
gotta lead us back to thinking okay
why were these kids allowed to be in a
freezer for 30 years to begin with and
and should we really allow that to
persist I don't think so speaking of new
people in our country
there is a there is a bill up that not a
lot of people are talking about because
I think that the liberal establishment
and the squish Republicans would rather
just get this thing passed in the dead
of night not have anybody talk about it
but it's a big problem it's called The
Eagle act the eagle Act is a green card
giveaway for Democrats and Fortune 500
CEOs
uh this is being peddled by the
Democrats but eight Republicans have
co-sponsored the bill
uh this includes representative Tom
emmer who unfortunately accidentally
because one guy voted incorrectly
mistakenly uh became the the whip for
the Republicans beating out Jim Banks
who's actually a conservative but you
got eight Republicans co-sponsoring this
bill and and what it does is it
supercharges citizenship incentives for
Indians and Chinese Nationals
to take Fortune 500 White Collar careers
over Americans over Americans who have
gone to college who have probably taken
out a lot of debt maybe quarter million
dollars maybe more than a quarter
million dollars in debt now immigrants
are going to get a faster track to that
and who wins
Democrats win because immigrants are
much more likely to vote for Democrats I
know I know the Republicans always say
well the immigrants they're they're
Republicans they just don't know it yet
uh yeah maybe we're still waiting on
that that still hasn't really quite
happened in certain small localities
sometimes immigrants break a little bit
for republicans and usually that's just
with the help of the Cubans who happen
to be extremely conservative but
generally speaking no the immigrants
vote for Democrats
and so it's a big win for the Democrats
electorally it's a big win for the big
corporations and for the Chamber of
Commerce that doesn't care about
anything really other than just boosting
its profit margins a little bit but it's
a big loss for the country okay the the
country has a responsibility politicians
have a responsibility to prioritize the
citizens of the country they have a
responsibility to prioritize their
constituents over
foreigners over
very wealthy influential CEOs
over
over all sorts of other vested interests
okay over the Democrats trying to rig
the elections they have a responsibility
to Americans okay a country is about
more than just GDP a country is about
more than just quarterly profits from a
handful of Corporations a country is
about more than just an idea meaning
that the country is really just an idea
of floating around the whole globe no
country is a real place with real people
with real borders with real geography
with real Traditions with a real way of
life okay and and uh it shows you how
tough this issue is because even the
Republicans
totally swish on immigration the vast
majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration legal
and illegal because it's just insanely
High three million people a year is just
crazy it's the largest movement of human
beings ever in recorded history over the
last 60 years into the United States and
so
the problem is the Democrats want much
much more of it because it gives them an
advantage and the Republicans
also kind of want more of it because
their donors demand it
and so what you're left with is the
toughest immigration position that we
get even from the most hard-line
immigration Hawks at the real top level
of politics is illegal bad legal good
illegal immigration is bad but legal
immigration is good so what do they do
they just changed a law to flood the
country with legal immigrants but the
effect of disruption of problems of
assimilation of suppressing wages of
taking jobs it's all the same right you
get the exact same
issue there
and so what are we going to do about it
it just shows you when even a republican
when even a conservative wants to go in
and fight the system he's got to fight a
lot more than just Joe Biden and some
Democrats he's got to fight the whole
system now even though old Joe and his
posse you're trying to Gaslight you into
believing that inflation is made up
never heard that word before until 2022
we all know that's not true
inflation is here
it's very real
you don't need me to tell you that what
you do need me to tell you however is
that I've got one neat treat trick to
beat inflation this year and that would
be starting this Friday for a limited
time we've got a Black Friday deal 50
off all new daily wire plus memberships
and gift membership save big if you are
a member this Friday you will be able to
watch the first two episodes of Jordan
Peterson's brand new series Exodus as
well as logos and literacy and Genesis
with a brand new introduction this will
make a fantastic gift for your family
your friends and for yourself too
perhaps the greatest gift of all is that
your membership allows us to continue
building the future that you want to see
2022 was big but 2023 will be huge so
come join us get 50 off your new daily
wire Plus Membership starting this
Friday dailywire.com subscribe you do
not want to miss it
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week tomorrow's
Thanksgiving so we wanted to do it on
Wednesday the mailbag the mailbag
sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code Knowles to get 50 off your first
month take it away
hey Michael my question this week is why
don't you like soccer I mean it really
seems like a great equalizer you don't
really have to have a lot of resources
to get started as long as you're willing
to practice and work hard and of course
have the athletic ability but with a
little drive and perseverance you can
really get good at it and you don't have
to have a ton of money to get started
honestly it sounds like the Great
American dream it it kind of mirrors
capitalism to be honest
um so what's your beef
that is my beef
that what you just described as my
specifically the first thing you said
you said it's a great equalizer
I'm a conservative so I don't like
everything to just be totally equal and
flattened I'm a conservative I like
order I like Nuance I like decoration I
like hierarchy I like I like variations
of skill I like complexity
I don't want everything to be totally
flattened down where you know you
compare a sport like baseball
extremely complex most people could not
tell you what the infield fly rule means
and you take a sport like soccer not
complex at all
you take a sport like Polo extremely
complex
soccer not complex at all
uh I don't want
I I don't think that we should be
encouraging sports that any
three-year-old can play okay I think
that we should be encouraging in
Civilization things that are difficult
and
complex and hard to understand and
require different types of athletic
ability at every different position for
that matter and you know I don't
necessarily think it should be the sort
of sport that you're totally priced out
of ever playing but it should involve
stuff you know it you should have to
have a real baseball diamond all right
and
uh that means that we're going to need
to encourage some charity from the
community when I was growing up it might
down the there was wasn't a particularly
wealthy town but
there was a rich guy who donated a lot
of money and we got a really beautiful
baseball diamond that's great I love all
that sort of stuff
if I were a lib
I would love soccer
but I'm not a lib next question
hi Michael let me start off by saying
that I love this show I came for Ben and
I stayed for Wilson I'm not a hugely
religious guy but after having my
children I am permanently against
abortion my question is that my wife
when she was 16 had an abortion she was
young dumb you know the girl
the issue is every time I tried to speak
to her about it about abortion in
general she feels like I am judging her
or attacking her which I truly believe
it's her own guilt that she is feeling
and she's judging herself your advice
would be greatly appreciated
how or should I try to talk to her about
it or should I just keep my thoughts to
myself on a fortune thanks Michael
appreciate it
it obviously is her own guilt and it's
such a Preposterous trick women
sometimes do this where if they'll do
something that is very bad and then if
you point this out you know or suggest
maybe you know you shouldn't do that or
whatever they'll say you're attacking me
stop attacking me and then sort of try
to evade the issue or try to invert the
situation but no it's obviously her own
conscience that is nagging at her and so
I don't think you should you know burn
her at the stake or anything like that
but
nor should you allow yourself to be
cowed into pretending that infanticide
is okay plenty of people have had
abortions
plenty and plenty of people have had
abortions okay I know many people and I
know uh my family members have had
abortions you know it's and it's really
awful and some of them have come to
regret them and some of them haven't
come to to regret them consciously at
least uh
but people fall into it it's very easy
to fall prey to that it's very easy to
fall parade of Temptation the only way
though that she's going to have Solace
from it
is to repent you know the first step on
the road to recovery is admitting you
have a problem and so you've got to do
that and I would recommend sacramental
confession uh I I think it is
I I believe there is a Sacrament that
was instituted by our Lord on this Earth
uh which gives priests the power to bind
and loose and to retain sins and to
forgive sins and I think that even if
you don't believe in the spiritual
efficacy of the sacrament of confession
as I do but even if you don't believe in
it
the psychological effects of that are
amazing when you actually hear someone
saying in the person of Christ I absolve
you of your sins that really lifts a
huge burden off of people and people
it's amazing with confession because
even
practicing Catholics myself included we
don't want to go to confession usually
because we say oh it's just so
embarrassing I've got to confess my sins
to a priest oh it's just you really
dread the whole thing and then you go
and the priest asserted everything
before priest has heard abortionless
before okay I promise you that and and
he says okay I absolve you every sins
say oh what a burden why have I been
carrying that around for weeks and weeks
or in the case of your wife years and
years and years
tell her to do it she's not she's not
going to feel any better by by denying
the issue next question
hey Michael it's me again
um yeah look I've been having a hard
time with a friend of mine
I see the way he treats his girlfriend
and I'm just not sure if I should say
something about it
it honestly makes me physically
uncomfortable and I don't know I just
generally feel awful for her so
uh I know these situations are tricky
and I'm just not sure if it's my
business or if I should look the other
way so
here it goes
um
my friend always lets his girl drive the
car and they're together
I mean what what should I do my gut
tells me he's either a closet homosexual
or he's forcing her to be his like
private chauffeur and neither of which
is in line with my king energy
philosophy
is it is it okay to be in a relationship
and let the women Drive
I would love to hear your opinion on
this also hypothetically if it turns out
that my buddy bats for the other team or
I don't know he's like a male feminist
or something
how long should I give it before I let
her ride shotgun with an absolute boss
sincerely Nick
I should have recognized your voice Nick
good to hear from you that's a good
question actually
uh it is you should confront your friend
about this
you should this is disordered
it is disordered for the man to have his
wife drive the car
I mean maybe you know if the man has had
one too many coca-colas at dinner then
it's very good for the wife to drive the
car but as a regular thing that is wrong
it is disordered
and you should
you should recognize as did uh one of
the in the early season of the crown you
know uh one of the uh head Butlers at
the palace tells the queen you know it's
it's in the little things that the rot
begins so it's in those little things
don't you can't
can't have that all right sit your
friend down have a talk with them next
question
hello Smokey Mike this is
your number one fan girl thank you so
much for the tough love a couple weeks
ago since then I've tried to reorder my
interests to more age-appropriate
content one TV show that I've tried
watching is the crown it was suggested
to me by a friend and he is very
obsessed with his majesty King Charles
III and that got me wondering why are so
many conservatives supportive of these
liberal train wrecks in Great Britain
now I understand the importance of
monarchy it can be an imperfect symbol
of the Heavenly Kingdom I also
understand the importance of tradition
especially as a traditional catholic
myself but I don't understand why so
many conservatives would support the
British Monarchy since they just seem
like glorified Kardashians to me who are
part of a church that was founded on
divorce so why would we support them
thanks love to hear your answer great
great question the the real blunt answer
to this is that we would support the
institution for the British you know the
British Monarchy for the British people
and then we would of course support
Franz the Duke of Bavaria or because he
is childless his brother Maximilian or
his daughter Sophie or more likely the
the young heir to the house of
wittelsbach and the Jacobite line of
succession Prince Joseph Wenzel of
Liechtenstein to come in land in
Scotland in a new Jacobite rising and
depose the the Windsors the SEC the sax
Coburg uh house kicked them out and then
take over and reinstitute a sort of uh
stable and proper uh family in in the
throne but assuming that's not going to
happen anytime soon why support these if
you support the monarchy in Britain
why support these people who are just
such a train wreck well I would say I I
am also watching this new season of the
ground
it focuses on the 90s which was the
worst decade for these people all of the
royal kids got divorced and there were
all these scandals and you know you had
you had like some pool boy sucking the
toes of of one of the duchesses on
paparazzi photos and you had Princess
Diana you know going out on all sorts of
dates and you know Charles talking about
wanting to live in his Mistresses
trousers and it was just and that was
before even a lot of the prince Andrew
stuff came out later with Jeffrey
Epstein it was just a very very bad
decade it was one of those years I think
it was 92 the queen referred to as her
anus oribilis
wait that shows you how a little emotion
the queen would show in public is even
when she was lamenting her true
misfortune
she would speak in Latin and uh so that
was a particularly bad time they've kind
of leveled off a little bit now but but
why why would we tolerate these people
one I think that King Charles III
actually has a kind of deep sort of
conservatism to him yes he's taken to
weird Flights of Fancy yes he's got all
this environmentalist stuff yes he has
paddled around with Klaus Schwab yeah
I'm not denying any of the problems with
him but he does
he's not a leftist okay you know the man
is sort of talked with a completely
locked John he drizzles like he's from
the 17th century and he does you know
he's not like a purple hair who's about
to go burn a bra down in downtown
um and also because if you support that
institution as a unifying and
stabilizing Institution for the country
and for the Commonwealth then
you support it no matter who's in the
seat
you know it's it's a a similar
similar thing with the Catholics you
know the Catholics recognize the Supreme
pontiff even if there is a bad Pope who
happens to be in the chair of Peter and
there have been plenty of bad popes
Dante puts a couple of popes in Hell
okay so uh that has happened but if you
support the institution you support the
institution that's that okay before we
uh get to the the member block let's get
to a an OG written mail-back question
girl advice from Alan
hello Michael
I've had a good friend who's a girl
she's both sweet and conservative I've
not seen her in person in two years
however we still text on a regular basis
I want to ask her out but I'm not quite
sure how to go about that I really
enjoyed your expert panel from last week
and all the women said to be confident
and Tall yeah I'm over six feet good
however this does scare me a bit any
advice would be great
well I would need a little more
information are you do you live near
this woman
you say you haven't seen her in two
years
you text a lot but then you said you
want to ask her out
so the first part makes me think you
don't live near her the second more
makes me think you do live near her
either way
yes you should either ask her out or
stop texting her it's really weird for
single men or a single man to text a
single woman
regularly for two years and not go on a
date that's really weird
so
yeah ask her out don't none of this
virtual parasocial kind of stuff do it
you know
put up or shut up let's let's go piss or
get off the pot I don't know how many
more
how many more idioms do I need to to
recite of course you should you should
ask her out as a normal it's good for
men and women to be attracted to each
other and to go on dates and to get
married and have lots of kids it is not
normal to remain in this permanent state
of tihi hey you up you know hey how are
you doing that's weird because then
you're you're not in a relationship with
a woman you're in a relationship with a
piece of technology and that's that's no
good that's no good at that point just
go data robot all right the rest of the
show continues now we have a very good
friend of mine coming on the show today
to talk about a new documentary and one
of the biggest biggest political issues
in America where probably some of the
most important political fights are
taking place that would be at the
schools the rest of the show continues
now if you are not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]